[Aplausos]
quién no ha soñado con no envejecer
con aprovechar la experiencia que nos
dan los años sin preocuparnos del
deterioro de nuestro cuerpo en convertir
en aliado y no en enemigo el paso del
tiempo se puede revertir el
envejecimiento reflexionemos juntos
queremos vivir más años pero con qué
calidad de vida qué consecuencias
sociales y económicas tendría este hecho
según datos de la organización mundial
de la salud en sólo 15 años se duplicará
la población de mayores de 60 años de
menos de 1000 millones en 2015 pasaremos
a más de 2 mil millones en 2050 españa
somos el país del mundo en tercer lugar
en esperanza de vida
actualmente los españoles vivimos en
torno a los 83 años y en 2060 rondaremos
los 90
pero estamos preparados para ello
nosotros pensamos que no aunque vivir
más años pueda significar una
oportunidad para desarrollar actividades
de interés la realidad es que el
envejecimiento estará marcado por un
factor nuestra salud y si el
envejecimiento está dominado por un
deterioro físico y mental créanme que
esto generará graves problemas
socioeconómicos para todos cada uno de
nosotros envejecemos de forma diferente
porque todos somos únicos e irrepetibles
por dos motivos nuestra genética que es
la información que nos transmiten
nuestros padres a través del adn y
nuestra epigenética que depende de la
interacción que hacemos a lo largo de
nuestra vida con el medio ambiente
factores como el estrés la alimentación
el tabaco el alcohol la contaminación
poniendo marcas en nuestro adn de tal
manera que habrá unos genes que se
expresen y otros no luego nuestro
envejecimiento que está marcado por el
deterioro de nuestras funciones y el
aumento de la probabilidad de padecer
enfermedades como diabetes enfermedad
cardiovascular enfermedades
degenerativas como parkinson o alzheimer
incluso cáncer está condicionado tanto
por nuestra genética como por nuestra
epigenética prevenir o curar estas
enfermedades es uno de los grandes
problemas de la ciencia actual uno de
los grandes retos ya ellos se dedican
científicos ilustres como el doctor
izpisúa desde el instituto sol en la
joya en california con el aporte
económico desinteresado y el apoyo
constante de personas como don josé luís
mendoza presidente de la universidad
católica san antonio de murcia que creen
en la ciencia como herramienta para
resolver los
es retos de la humanidad y en ello
estamos trabajando y desarrollando
proyectos conjuntos en la frontera del
conocimiento para trasladar los
resultados a toda la sociedad permítanme
que comience hablándoles de uno de los
proyectos que llevamos a cabo sobre la
generación de órganos humanos para
trasplante el aumento de la esperanza de
vida hace que cada vez más personas
necesiten un trasplante de hecho el
número de órganos para trasplante se ha
incrementado su necesidad
exponencialmente en los últimos años
el número de trasplantes que se hacen
anualmente en el mundo supera los 125
mil y créanme si les digo que este dato
apenas cubre el 10 por ciento de la
demanda y de dónde proceden estos
órganos pues hasta ahora de donaciones
de otras personas pero sin duda esto no
es suficiente 'españa con el modelo
puesto en marcha por la organización
nacional de trasplantes es el primer
país del mundo en índice de donaciones
pero como digo no es suficiente
necesitamos buscar alternativas en
definitiva generar órganos se ha
convertido en un reto tanto científico
como social los investigadores
pensamos que animales superiores como el
cerdo podrán convertirse en verdaderas
incubadoras de órganos humanos para
trasplante insertando en sus embriones
humanas ips y ustedes se preguntarán y
qué son las células ips pues las células
ips son células madre generadas en un
laboratorio a partir de células adultas
y que podrán convertirse en cualquier
célula de nuestro cuerpo de cualquier
tejido a este proceso se le llama
reprogramación celular fue descubierto
por el doctor yamanaka y por ello
recibió el premio nobel en 2012 el nobel
de medicina con este experimento sentó
las bases de la medicina regenerativa el
equipo de investigadores liderado por el
doctor izpisúa al cual tengo el enorme
privilegio de pertenecer hemos dado
grandes pasos en este campo en nuestro
laboratorio hemos conseguido crear
ratones con órganos de rata utilizando
células
para ello
manipulamos embriones de ratón a los que
les eliminamos las células que darían
lugar al corazón páncreas u ojos y en su
lugar insertamos células ips de rata
estos embriones manipulados se
insertaron en hembras de ratón
receptoras y se les dejó continuar su
desarrollo
normalmente pasados unos 20 días
nacieron ratones con páncreas corazón y
ojos de rata pero nosotros lo que
queremos es generar órganos humanos y
por eso decidimos trabajar con cerdos
los órganos de estos animales tienen un
tamaño y fisiología mucho más parecidos
a los nuestros y con la experiencia que
habíamos adquirido trabajando con
ratones reproducimos el mismo mecanismo
insertamos células ips humanas en
embriones de cerdo posteriormente
y embriones fueron implantados en celdas
receptoras y continuaron con su
desarrollo pasados unos días pudimos
comprobar que las células humanas habían
sobrevivido y se estaba especializando
para dar lugar a los distintos
progenitores de los distintos tejidos el
experimento lo mantuvimos hasta la
cuarta semana de gestación y los
resultados obtenidos pasado este tiempo
fueron la prueba de concepto de que
efectivamente se pueden insertar células
ips humanas en embriones de animales
superiores con el fin de generar órganos
humanos para trasplante como corazón
hígado páncreas o riñón si importante es
generar órganos humanos
igual de importante es regenerar órganos
estropeados en vivo para centrarnos en
este proyecto seleccionamos la piel la
piel es el órgano que cubre todo nuestro
cuerpo y que nos protege de las
agresiones externas pero la piel se
deteriora con el envejecimiento o con
accidentes graves como puedan ser los
grandes quemados mediante reprogramación
celular
conseguimos regenerar piel de ratón en
la propia herida para ello tratamos las
células de la herida con los factores de
yamanaka y conseguimos estas células
convertirlas en células madre
posteriormente estas células se
diferenciaron para dar lugar a los
distintos tipos de células que componen
nuestra piel regenerando piel sana en
sólo 18 días sin necesidad de
trasplantes ni de injertos
continúo con otro de los proyectos que
estamos llevando a cabo en este proyecto
mediante el diseño de herramientas de
edición génica tratamos de reparar
tejidos y órganos dañados por
enfermedades que surgen con el
envejecimiento la primera tecnología que
desarrollamos de edición génica la
llamamos heat y está basada en el uso de
la tijera molecular christer de la que
seguro que todos hemos oído hablar con
esta técnica conseguimos por primera vez
insertar en células que no se dividen
genes correctos es decir podíamos cortar
el genoma de células del corazón de la
retina del sistema nervioso o del
sistema muscular para demostrar la
efectividad de esta técnica
nos centramos en una enfermedad la
retinosis pigmentaria esta enfermedad
hace que los individuos que le aparezcan
vayan quedándose ciegos con el tiempo
llegando a la ceguera total esta
provocada por la mutación de una serie
de genes entre los que se encuentra el
gen mert este gen es el responsable de
que se sintetiza una proteína que es la
responsable de la recepción de la luz en
nuestros ojos conseguimos un modelo de
rata que estaba mutado en el gen ver las
ratas sanas como observamos en el corte
histológico de la retina sintetizan
perfectamente la proteína en rojo que es
la responsable de recibir la luz por lo
tanto son ratas que pueden ver y como
observamos en el vídeo la rata es capaz
de seguir el movimiento de los barrotes
las ratas mutadas las ratas enfermas
son incapaces de sintetizar la proteína
responsable de recibir la luz porque
están mutadas en el gen med y por lo
tanto son ratas que no ven y no siguen
el movimiento de los barrotes como vemos
en el vídeo utilizando la tecnología que
hemos diseñado llamada heat y hemos sido
capaces de insertar en las células de la
retina de ratas ciegas una copia
correcta del gen med
pasadas ocho semanas del tratamiento
hicimos un análisis de los cortes
histológicos de la retina y vimos que la
proteína roja volvía a sintetizar se
luego estas ratas debían volver a ver
analizando el vídeo observamos que la
rata vuelve a seguir el movimiento de
los barrotes e incluso se eleva
siguiendo el foco de la luz
luego concluimos que hit y cura la
retinosis pigmentaria
diseñamos otra herramienta también para
cortar el genoma y también basada en el
uso de la tijera molecular crisis pero
en este caso la llamamos zatti y para
demostrar su efectividad nos centramos
en otra enfermedad la progeria esta
enfermedad produce un envejecimiento
prematuro de los individuos que la
padecen debido a una mutación en el gen
lmn a este gen es el responsable de la
síntesis de una proteína llamada lámina
y cuando el gen está mutado se sintetiza
una proteína errónea que se denomina pro
gen ina esta proteína es la responsable
de una inestabilidad en la membrana del
núcleo celular lo que conlleva a una
lectura errónea del genoma mediante el
uso de shati insertamos en ratones con
progeria una copia correcta del gen
estos ratones rejuvenecieron de forma
general y aumentaron en un 35% su vida
útil lo que equivale aproximadamente a
10 años en humanos estos ratones nos
dimos cuenta que realmente habían
rejuvenecido todos sus tejidos pasando a
sintetizar la proteína correcta lámina y
dejando de sintetizar la proteína
progerina en este vídeo vamos a ver dos
ratones gemelos ambos con progeria uno
tratado con zatti y otro no creo que
todos podemos saber cuál es cuál
luego sad y revierte el envejecimiento
en este punto nos planteamos si somos
capaces de rejuvenecer organismos
completos editando el genoma seremos
capaces de hacerlo evitando su epigenoma
borrando las marcas que el paso del
tiempo ha puesto en el adn pues
actualmente sabemos que la
reprogramación celular diseñada por
yamanaka es un experimento epigenético
en el que se borran casi todas las
marcas del adn basándonos en este
concepto
tratamos ratones envejecidos normalmente
con los factores de yamanaka pero
durante periodos cortos de tiempo y el
resultado lo podemos ver en las dos
imágenes de la pantalla
los ratones incrementaron su vida útil
en aproximadamente un 30% además de
observarse un rejuvenecimiento
generalizado de sus tejidos
con este experimento demostramos que
mediante reprogramación celular podemos
rejuvenecer organismos completos todas
las técnicas que acabamos de describir
aquí y que han sido publicadas en las
revistas de impacto mayores de todo el
mundo como neichel science o cell
demuestran que se puede revertir el
envejecimiento son muchos los pasos que
nos faltan todavía por dar para poder
trasladar estas tecnologías a humanos
sin duda es necesario incrementar para
ello la colaboración entre investigación
básica e investigación aplicada hemos
avanzado mucho en animales pero nosotros
queremos curar personas y para ello
seguiremos trabajando sol y ucam hasta
que podamos conseguirlo y entre tanto
tal y como ya nos dijo gandhi vivamos
como si fuéramos a morir mañana
aprendamos como si fuéramos a vivir
siempre muchas gracias
[Aplausos]